listen
the
the restaurant
the nft restaurant yeah are we are we
good to come through
well if we don't have an nf if we don't
have the
the membership can we just slide through
the back door or something like that
i mean if you put them if you want to
put on like if you want to punch in and
work
[Laughter]
you can go through the back to the
employee entrance
i got i got good news for you guys when
you guys come to new york and q1
early next year
i've got a couple of seats that are my
table thing it would be a genuine
pleasure
oh hell yeah have dinner with you guys
and chop it up and get to know each
other better and we will do it in fly
fish club because chef caipon and
chef khan like this is what's so great
about getting older like these are two
chefs that i've watched in new york do
their [ __ ] thing for 20 years so like
the lack of anxiety i have that we are
going to dominate the food program and
that we are going to be super on point
so be really fun to to do that with you
guys
i would love i honestly would love that
yeah
it's the same i would i would love to
are you guys into wine
um
i'll drink it
right but you don't nerd on it no no
what about bourbon
not really i know a little bit about gin
no [ __ ] it's funny i've been thinking a
lot more about gin because jyn hasn't
popped insane yet and so that's like the
white space you know that's exactly
that's exactly what i was thinking
yeah
yeah literally took the words out of my
mouth
yeah
yeah so yeah
i know i know this is like my time but
i'm enjoying this so much and i'm sure
there's like like i know how these
things go there's probably some things
we can get to so i'm just going to hang
for five more minutes if you allow me to
and i'll be late for my next meeting for
sure oh absolutely
that'd be [ __ ] perfect i mean dude
okay
you're so good at giving advice i wanted
to put you in an unethical context all
right if someone
if someone is down bad and they needed
to steal what would you tell them to
steal
whatever was most stealable
okay
right i mean like
like like like if you work at tar like
if you work at my dad's wine store
like and you're in stocking shelves like
steal the expense of wine okay okay like
if you work at vayner like oh see which
offices are open in the executive's room
and take the most expensive like listen
employees are you enjoying this [ __ ]
geez
listen you ask me the question i have to
give you the answer
what do you think the worst advice
you've ever given what is it do you
think
you know i'll be i'll be vulnerable here
i
didn't understa this is actually funny
as gary garyvee on stage because i'm
talking to masses i think candor is a
strength of mine i like want to go to
the punch line
as an executive
because i've been building business my
whole life i actually really struggled
with candor i didn't i don't like
confrontation
i
and i always thought that i could
[ __ ] figure it out i knew that i
didn't value the money enough and i
liked my people my team my home like i
really from day like day one was like
employees family like i was really about
that life and so i'd always try to like
figure it out
and so early in my career when my best
friend joined i was like look
if someone sucks you don't tell them you
try to manage around it and build them
up and get them there
and in hindsight it was bad advice
now what i've learned is
what ended up happening was i realized
man there's been people that have worked
for me that don't like me and i was like
how could that be because i don't like i
know who i am like i don't value the
money enough i love the people this is
something's broken i was like [ __ ] it's
the candor i would i'd be like cody
you're great like cody great hair day
cody good [ __ ] and then out of nowhere
on tuesday i'd be like yo cody got five
minutes so cody listen we're gonna have
to let you go what the [ __ ]
and and and he was like you said my hair
was awesome on friday i'm like yeah but
you know like and you know as a kid you
can still be you can still be unemployed
and have great hair so later and so
so i really struggled with candor and
somewhere around four or five years ago
i switched up my game because i had to
have that moment where i was like look
what can i be better at what the [ __ ]
not working
and and i put this concept of kind
candor into my head i'm like look i can
tell somebody they're really not good at
their job but i can unscare them by
being aggressive about contextualizing
it and communicating it's really helped
me so to answer your question the worst
advice i gave in my i would have made
videos about this back then and i would
have been wrong my evolution helped me
get there is if someone's like not good
actually letting them know and trying to
build them up from it is dramatically
better than
trying to work around it because you as
the owner or the manager will gate will
get resentment over the time and then
eventually you'll just have this kind of
like either you'll subconsciously force
them out and they've sensed it and they
don't like that or you'll drop that
tuesday morning bomb when friday was
awesome and then you're really not doing
the right thing and that's something
i've had to work on
damn it was deep it was deep that's a
great answer i mean in these la in this
last buzzer beater minute i'm gonna try
to throw you throw another one out here
um
you are obviously a connoisseur of nfts
you know about a lot of nfts who's got
the ugliest nft art
are you
goading me
into
yeah i could hear the background i mean
the answer is me
you know i thought i was doing a good
thing because you know it had to be
provenance and i was gonna draw it and
it came from my soul and i was gonna
doodle and i was like all proud of it i
was like you know this is important if
i'm gonna build this disney pokemon
transformers-like world from day one the
fact that it came from my heart and my
brain and my soul and my [ __ ]
sharpies that's authentic and i was like
all proud as [ __ ] it comes out it
crushes but like everyone's like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] these kindergarten
drawings suck [ __ ] my [ __ ]
three-year-old niece can and i was like
and so
like there's a lot of people that think
be friends is actually the answer
damn it does seem like it does kind of
seem like
like a commentary on the whole thing
like it seems kind of ironic a little
bit well i'll tell you it's actually the
reverse it's ironic if you think it's
all about the subjective art
it's incredibly not ironic if you
understand what nfts are which is
contractual utilities
that can do so many other things that
they are the gateway to my conference
when i build my ip when i build my
disney world and the original v friends
is lifetime pass people can be like oh
[ __ ] like people don't understand where
this world's going they're
underestimating it the way they
underestimate youtube when i was there
day one and oh six the way they
underestimated the internet the way they
underestimated twitter [ __ ] tick tock
it's all the same [ __ ] bro people
underestimate the new because they don't
have enough curiosity confidence or
patience to see it through
damn
bars bar right there there you go
put that on a beat man
fellas listen to me
i see you you guys have real [ __ ]
talent i cheer for you thank you man
thank you so much gary we appreciate you
for coming on thank you so much for
doing this we really appreciate it of
course take care brother next meeting
man bye real nice meeting you guys you
too see you in january oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] damn well that's gonna line up real
well with all our nft jokes and the
bonus yeah
i forgot we already [ __ ] did
the we already did the bonus and it's
just an hour's worth of us
[Music]
and nfts and
wow that's going to be a perfect
transition but no it's fine it's you
know that that's our um visual
accountability you know yeah people can
run that back we're just playing the
same game as gary i'm playing both sides
so that i always come out on top exactly
like
once yeah when we're at the restaurant
actually and we and we take a picture
and we're at the nft restaurant
someone's gonna reply and be like
remember when you said this on crypto
land we're like yeah yeah we do remember
that now we're eating [ __ ] fish
thanks to an nft
so you know it is what it is it is what
it is
you